the seven are gods of weakness and
defeat pretty chains that the first men
kindly put on after the Andals crushed
them except in the Iron Islands since
the dawn age the Ironborn have followed
the drowned God who plucked fire from
the sea and made us to Reeve and sack
and carve our names in blood and song
when the Andals landed on the Iron
Islands
they found a God who was father warrior
and stranger who took mother maiden and
Crone when he would and held the Smith
in thrall his priests are the drowned
men who are clothed and armed by the sea
itself
they consecrate us to the drowned God
through our most sacred Rite the
drowning and ask the God to raise us
from the sea as he was harder and
stronger the Ironborn do not fear the
bloodiest battles or the roughest waves
for the drowned God taught us long ago
that what is dead may never die when an
iron born falls we say the drowned God
needed a strong oarsmen and took him
below to feast in the gods watery halls
attended by mermaids but even in death
an Ironborn is a warrior we fight
against the storm God who holds the
castle in the clouds and sends the winds
to Leo the Ironborn of course or wrecker
ships it said my legendary ancestor the
grey King waged war upon the storm guard
for a thousand years with the drowned
God's help he slew the great sea dragon
nagger and used her bones for his home
after his death the storm God tried to
wash away any memory of this terrible
foe but his songs fill our halls to this
day it was the storm God who first blew
the Andals to the iron islands to subdue
us and turn us from our faith true they
conquered and killed our King but in
time they forsook their septs for the
shore and their fat septons for the
drowned men
the Andals came to us as conquerors in
the end they drowned the Ironborn of the
sea as our God made us and given to it
as our God taught us we do not fear the
storm God's winds or his waves but you
should for they bring us to you